هل يمكنني أن أسألك يا دانييل لأنك كتبت
مقالة مهمة لصحيفة نيويورك
تايمز وقد حددت
شيئين، أحدهما بالتأكيد دعوت به
إلى وقف إطلاق النار ولكن جزئيًا لإخراج
الرهائن،
أخبرنا كيف تقصد ولماذا ذلك
العمل أو كيف يمكن أن يعمل ذلك
وسط شيء كهذا، لذلك أعتقد أن
ما نراه في الوقت الحالي هو أن الطريق
المحتمل نحو وقف كامل لإطلاق النار
ربما يمر عبر وقف محدود
للأعمال
العدائية يسمح لبعض
الرهائن بالخروج  ربما
يؤدي الخروج بعد ذلك إلى التوصل إلى
اتفاق لخروج الباقين، أعتقد أنه
بمجرد أن يتعلق الأمر بالجنود الذين تحتجزهم
حماس، فسيكون ذلك في
تبادل أسرى أكثر أهمية وأعتقد أن
ما ربما نتحرك
نحوه هو أنه سيكون هناك  أعتقد أننا
نتحدث الآن ربما عن توقف لمدة خمسة أيام لمدة
خمسة أيام، وإخراج
عدد كبير من المحتجزين من المحتمل أن يتم
إطلاق سراح النساء والأطفال الفلسطينيين المحتجزين في السجون الإسرائيلية
مقابل الحصول على ضخ أكبر بكثير
من المساعدات الإنسانية، ولكن بعد ذلك هناك
أمران  حدث يا كريستيان وأظهرت
المسيرة داخل إسرائيل
لإطلاق سراح الرهائن وتحدثت
عن الديناميكية في
المحادثة الداخلية الإسرائيلية وأعتقد أن
شيئين سيحدثان إذا
حدث إطلاق سراح الرهائن الأول، فإن ديناميكية
المحادثة داخل إسرائيل تتغير
وأنت  سيكون لدينا المزيد من الضغط لإخراج
الباقي ومن ثم يصبح الاختيار واضحًا،
إما المهمة العسكرية أو
إطلاق سراح السجناء والشيء الآخر
الذي يحدث هو الضغط الخارجي
الذي يتراكم الآن،
الغرب يلعب لعبة اللحاق بركب
أمريكا وأوروبا.  اللحاق بركب
بقية العالم كان هناك
قبل ذلك بكثير أن هذا يجب أن ينتهي، لكن
الضغط الخارجي بمجرد حدوث
توقف لمدة 5 أيام، هل سيكون من السهل على
إسرائيل استئناف هذا النوع من
القصف وقتل
الشعب الإسرائيلي بشكل جيد؟  يريدون أن يروا، بالطبع
يريدون استعادة أحبائهم ولكنهم
يريدون أن يروا استمرارًا للحرب
أيضًا ويريدون تحييد
حماس، لذا، ونعم، وقد
أشرنا إلى نوع من عدم الارتياح الآن
بين بعض أقوى الدول
يتحدث الجميع عن حلفاء إسرائيل إذا تم
تدمير حماس وتحييدها
سياسيًا
وعسكريًا، فماذا بعد ذلك نعرف أن رئيس
نتنياهو قد اغتنم الفرصة مرتين أو ثلاث مرات
للتحدث إلى
وسائل الإعلام الأمريكية في كل مرة نوعًا من تحريك
المرمى حول ما ستفعله إسرائيل
بعد ذلك أولاً  هل تعلم أن
الوجود الأمني ​​في المستقبل المنظور
كان ظرفًا عسكريًا
سمعناه للتو في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع ما مدى الرغبة في ذلك
جيدًا وأعتقد أن إسرائيل دخلت في
هذا دون خطة واضحة
للصباح التالي ومن أجل فهم
ذلك  أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى أن نفهم أن
إسرائيل قد أهملت إلى حد كبير فكرة
أن المرء يمارس السياسة مع
الفلسطينيين ويمارس نهجًا موجهًا نحو الحل،
وبالتالي كان من
الصعب الحصول على هذه الإجابة بأي نوع
من الطريقة الواضحة الآن، وأعتقد أن
النتيجة الأكثر ترجيحًا هي أن حماس
ستستمر في الوجود، قد يتم تخفيض قدرتها العسكرية
سياسيا، ربما تكون أقوى مما كانت عليه من
قبل، ستظل هناك
حماس، كيف تنتهي الصراعات عندما
يجد أهل العنف في نهاية المطاف طرقا
للخروج من ذلك، وأن الفلسطينيين ليسوا في عجلة من أمرهم للجلوس مع إسرائيل بعد انتهاء الصراع.
مقتل 4.5 ألف
طفل وبالطبع الإسرائيليون
يريدون إزالة حماس ولكن هذا
تقريباً بعد مقتل 1400 بعد
مقتل
1200 لكن الأرقام لا تهم
لقد كانت
مروعة لذلك هذا غير واقعي  من ناحية
نتوقع أن حركة متأصلة في
شعب يعيش بدون حرية
وحقوق لن تكون هناك
مقاومة مسلحة، لكن الجزء الآخر من
هذه المعادلة بالطبع
هو ماذا عن السلطة الفلسطينية وماذا عن عباس
وماذا عن هذا
الجانب الآخر برمته وهذا  هو ما هو مفقود